jimmy lee says
okay i'm interested what kind of theory
of everything does survivor man has how
does he feel about the great reset
and the technocratic neo-feudalism which
we seem to be headed for
so how does he feel about the great
reset
firstly what the what is the great reset
and then how do you feel about it
i'm assuming he's talking when he says
the great reset i assume i'm assuming
he's talking about right now this moment
in time with the pandemic because that's
what everybody's called on the great
reset
um and and
uh
how do i feel about it what an
interesting way to ask that how do i
more about the technocratic
neo-feudalism we seem to be headed for
just this morning
i was thinking that here's how i feel
about it
that i want to turn my back on it and
continue creating
because
getting caught up in all of that going
on around us is not good for the soul
uh
if it's your thing
okay
but i gotta be honest
it's never been my thing to get caught
up in these big moments in time like
this in fact when i was an outdoor guide
stuff used to come and go in the world
and i barely even knew i'm not saying be
selfish live selfishly but what i'm
saying is i better serve
this
greater theory of everything if you will
if i am
putting
content out that uplifts people inspires
people brings about a positive influence
on people's lives i better i'm better
served and i better serve this great
thing that's that's going on we call
live if i concentrate on that and i and
i'm not copying out from the question
i'm saying it's
i
i turn back i turn my back on it
on that question because i i
just it'd be a waste of my energy to try
to be to try to even have a feeling
about it right now you know